النار بالنار مسلسل لبناني السوري بطوله
عابد فهد جورج خباز وكاريس بشار وطوني
عيسى وزينه مكي والعمل من تاليف رامي كوسا
واخراج محمد عبد العزيز ومن اول ما طلع
هذا العمل عامل حاله جدل كبيره بين
السوريين واللبنانيين وتعليقات كثيره بين
اتهامات بالجراه في الطرح والترحيب
بالموضوع وبين اتهامات ثانيه باشعال نعرض
العنصريه بين البلدين والشعبان اول الجدل
بدا بمشهد كان بين كاريس بشار اللي بتقوم
بدور مريم اللاجئ السوريه اللي هربت من
سوريا واستقرت في لبنان وبين جورج خباز
عزيز اللي بيكون مدرس موسيقى انطوائي شفنا
في المشهد الشخصيه السوريه اللاجئ بتقول
اللبناني يا فينيقي وهو بيرد بطريقه ساخره
انه ما حنكتب لكم بالفرنسي لانه ما راح
تفهموا امس جرعه الانتقادات والتعليقات
زادت بعد مشهد جديد المشهد ايضا لكريس
بشار وفي بتروح تتصور على شان تطلع جواز
سفر لبناني وبيطلب منا المصور خلع الحجاب
علشان تبين لبنانيه بحسب النص مسلسل كاتب
المسلسل رامي كوسا من بدايه العمل المشارك
في الانتقادات والجدل وبينشر بوستات
بينتقد فيها تعديلات كثيره في النص وزاد
الانتقادات اكثر بعد مشهد امس وقال انه
الجمله اللي قالها المصور انه ما راح تبين
لبنانيه مو موجوده ابدا في الحوار اللي هو
كتبه وانه تمت اضافتها من قبل احد ما يعرف
مين هو لكن اكيد بموافقه المخرج المخرج
كان طلع امس في منشور على صفحته على
فيسبوك وقال انه كل التعديلات اللي صارت
كانت بمعرفه الشركه المنتجه وكل شيء انحذف
كان من ضمن البروفات علشان تناسب توجهات
المشهد